well
[Music]
hector mejía greets you with the headlines
for today, thursday, november 19, the
governor says only actis is ready
to announce new measures to
reduce the spread of the virus in the
state in a call made yesterday the
governor specified that the
strategies used to date  now they
were not enough his team will meet
to review the latest information
collected regarding
confirmed cases and will continue firm with his plan
called stay at home 2.0
meanwhile more sites to
be tested for the virus
open today now you can attend this afternoon
and tomorrow  in the morning when transcribing
run in technical la carme located
near cement and vegas drive for more
information on schedules you can
visit our page of kirchner
dotcom diagonal in Spanish
today is sentencing day for the woman
convicted of being drunk and drugged
at the moment  of killing two teenagers
in a vehicle crash in August and
biling  the chlorine man ran over and killed two
16 year old girls while they were crossing he
wanted to come near the maryland parkway
he is expected to get a sentence of 10
to 25 years in prison
and now we turn to the weather forecast
we will have a sunny and clear day
but a maximum  72 degrees
however we will again have some
breezes in the valley while the
temperatures will drop to around the
sixties for the rest of the week
have a nice diary I'm héctor mejía
and this was your brief news on
kirchner in spanish
[Music]